effectively if the committee decides an
empty lot of us are equal to their
finished that sense it's all power to
the committee more power to the
institution no power to the vote of it
is a committee really likely sane MP
crosses the floor to say no actually we
think this chapter today well that's the
other problem is the criteria so narrow
that it's almost meaningless in any case
that's very hard to imagine an MP so an
MP would only qualify for serious
financial on day so as an MP i could
join the BNP even though no one in my
pack squirted vampy I could break every
promise i've ever made politically i
could go on holiday to Barbados for a
year I could refuse to go to Parliament
refused to shake the hands of my
constituents and I would not qualify
under this proposal for r equal so the
danger with this and it is a real danger
I think particularly now when so many
people are Hannity politics is that the
very next scandal voters will realize
that they've been duped the next time
and MP gets into terrible trouble for
whatever reason you know they're getting
to travel voters will learn that they
can't recall that MP and that this
recall bill is worth absolutely nothing
they have no more power after this bill
than they do today and I think the sense
of betrayal the sense of anger will be
immense people won't just think
politicians allows they'll know
politicians alliance so the government
are dipping the public with this ability
think a hundred percent this is a
pretense this isn't a ten deliberate do
you think that he's got it wrong I think
I think it's deliberate I think there's
a real reluctance to trust people with
democracy and this is as far as they're
willing to go to seem as though they
honor the promise of his important
before the election in the key to the
expenses scandal without actually
honoring that moments but i think the
gum i think it's going to backfire i
don't think this is safer as an MP i
would feel very safe in a pure legal
system if I screw up and i'm due to have
that's democracy but under the under the
government's proposal all it would take
is a fallible whip controlled committee
of MPs perhaps terrified in the glaze of
hostile publicity to point their finger
it means to equality
to equal and I know that at that point
might be finished I would not be able to
allowing a good judge of the nap of my
constituents but I wouldn't have that
opportunity